What if the President of the United States
decides to launch a nuclear strike?
President Trump started 2018 with a tweet chiding
North Korea’s leader Kim Jong Un that “he
too has a nuclear button”....
And it’s “bigger and more powerful”
than Kim's
But launching a missile involves much more
than pushing a button.
And really, there is no button.
Here’s what would actually need to happen.
The president must first discuss the plan
with a group of military and civilian advisers.
That group includes the Pentagon’s deputy
director of operations, and the head of U.S.
Strategic Command- anyone else in the group
is at the President’s discretion.
The call either takes place in the White House
Situation Room or the president can be patched
in on a secure line.
Some of the advisers may try to change the
president’s mind or resign in protest, but
ultimately, the Pentagon must do whatever
the commander-in-chief orders.
That meeting with advisors can be as short
as 30 seconds.
Next the president gives the order to launch.
But before the Pentagon can prepare the launch
order, it must first verify that the
person ordering the strike is indeed the president.
An officer in the Pentagon’s war room reads
what’s known as a “challenge code”.
For example, “Delta-Echo.”
The president retrieves the “biscuit,”
a laminated card the president or a military
aide carries at all times, and finds the matching
response to the challenge code:
For example, “Charlie-Zulu”.
Once the codes match, the launch order goes
out.
The war room prepares a message containing
the war plan, time of launch, authentication
codes and the codes needed to unlock the missiles
before firing them.
That message is only about 150 characters
long
It’s encoded, encrypted and broadcast to
launch crews.at this point only about 2-to-3
minutes may have passed since the initial
conference call.
Within seconds, a submarine and five ICBM
crews in various underground bunkers receive
the launch orders.
They open safes and compare their Sealed Authentication
System codes (SAS) to those sent by the war
room.
This will confirm that the order is authentic.
If the codes match, the crews enter the war
plan number into their launch computers.
They type additional code to unlock the missiles,
and at the designated time of launch, the
five crews simultaneously turn a launch key
retrieved from their safe…
It only takes two crews to launch, so three
can refuse to do any of the prior steps and
the missile or missiles will still fire.
For missiles are launched from a submarine,
there is no second key - the crew has full
power to launch.
From here, there is no turning back.
It’s been about AS LITTLE AS 5 minutes from
the time the president decided to launch a
nuclear missle to the time the missle or missile(s)
blast out of their silos.
It will take submarine missiles an additional
15 minutes until they shoot out of their tubes.
Once it fires, a missile and its warhead cannot
be called back.